Jamie Lee Curtis well give me a couple
Jamie Lee Curtis movies she was in
Halloween she was in that show with uh
what was that show with Richard Lewis
and her that was on for a couple years
not mad about you mad about shoe no what
the hell is that show anything but love
I think it was called anything but love
Richard Lewis Jamie Lee Curtis
ing anything but love
Richard Lewis Jamie Lee Curtis come on
Google listening anything but love I got
it was pretty decent show actually
anyway she's done a couple things over
the years what was the deal with her she
was born intersex she had like testicles
and a vagina or something anyway great
gal she also has that she she's big on
Activia which is the uh the yogurt when
you have stomach problems
whatever uh here she is apparently she
won an Oscar and she's naming her Oscar
or she's using the Oscar's preferred
pronouns of they them because of her
trans son or daughter take a look
I'm I'm in support of my daughter Ruby
I'm I'm having them be a they them oh
um I'm I'm gonna just call them them
they them and um they are doing great
a Hollywood actress hugging and stroking
her ridiculous award to because that she
got because she pretends to do something
uh in honor of her trans child is just
like the perfect it's just perfect it's
just perfect I think we have a picture
of her they them daughter or son
I will leave that without commentary
because my mom's probably watching and
she wants me to be nicer so we'll let
that be uh but it never ends it never
ends with these people
[Music]
thank you